hallo ihr Lieben warte mal als
ich so gemacht hat voll gespannt
okay
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute Lemon Curd
rolls das sind ganz fluffige Hefeteige mit
einer Zitronencreme also super erfrischend
ich habe jetzt hier direkt meine Schüssel
und werde jetzt den Hefeteig hierhin äh
zubereiten ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben und nehmen die
nächste Box genau das ist unter dem Titel die
Videobeschreibung einfach aufmachen und dann
könnt ihr euch das Screenshot und einkaufen
gehen bei mir gebe ich euch aber direkt einen
Tipp nicht alles rein zu tun weil je nachdem
wie groß das Ei ist könnte es sein dass sie
ein bisschen weniger oder auch ein bisschen
mehr braucht so und zum Mehl gebe ich jetzt
ich mache so eine Mulde und das ist richtig
rein Filmen wenn man das sieht so so eine Mode
bilden und dann kommt da einmal lauwarme mich
gucken da gebe ich jetzt lauwarme Milch hinzu
die dürfte jetzt auch nicht zu heiß sein also
wirklich nur erwärmen auf so ca 38 Grad und
hinzu kann auch direkt die frische Hefe wer
keine frische Hefe da hat kein Problem
dann könnt ihr auch trockene Hefe nehmen
schreibe ich euch dann auch in die Infobox
wieder die Mengenangaben sind so direkt dazu
einmal Zucker schöner Nährstoff für die Hefe
gibt aber auch Geschmack ab und das Eier so
quasi alle flüssigen Zutaten das Ei und die
zerlassene Butter kommen noch mit hinzu und
dann fange ich einfach an zu kneten und gibt
nach und nach das restliche Mehl dazu [Musik]
den Hefeteig habe ich jetzt erst in der
Schüssel kurz zusammengeknetet und dann
habe ich persönlich mein besseres Gefühl auf der
Arbeitsfläche und sonst habe ich hier eine feine
kleine Kugel geformt und die wird jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen Ruhezeit benötigen um einfach
aufzugeben dafür nehmt euch am besten so ein
bisschen Öl ich nehme hier backtrennspray weil
mehr möchte ich jetzt nicht dazu geben weil das
Mehl verarbeitet sich ja auch beim rufvorgang in
den Teig und dann ist der Teig eventuell doch
so trocken noch ein bisschen Öl oben drüber
und dann luftdicht verschließen und jetzt 30
Minuten ruhen lassen und dann geht's weiter
mit der leckeren zitronenfüllung so die Ruhezeit
ist vorbei und jetzt wird der Teig einmal kurz
ausgebreitet ich habe hier meinen ausrollstab
3 mm sind die Abstandsringe die ich jetzt hier
drauf tue ihr könnt das natürlich auch nach
Augenmaß machen aber wenn man schon so tolle
kleine Helferlein hat dann muss man die natürlich
auch nutzen so die eine Seite dann auch noch die
andere wenn ihr jetzt eine Oberfläche habt die
wunderbar Antirutsch ist dann ist es super dann
klebt da nämlich auch nichts an ich habe jetzt
hier sicherheitshalber einfach noch die Silikon
Backmatte unten drunter plus ich habe jetzt hier
auch noch schöne zentimeterangaben und euch gebe
ich ja auch mal die Zentimeter Angaben an weil ich
weiß nicht wie es ist immer dann zu Hause sitzt
ich hätte gern schon noch die ein oder andere
Info damit mir das auch gut gelingt wenn z.B
haben sie das Rezept ist nachmachen würde der
ist doch dankbar über jede Information gehört
aber eins zu dem Gedächtnis geblieben
in Bio warst du richtig gut und ich war
richtig schlecht in Bio und habe so soll ich das
erzählt bei der notenbesprechung ne die die ruft
sie jeden einzeln raus sagt so ja haben sie was
was denken Sie daran so richtig selbstbewusst
alle haben gesagt super das ist gut das hat
Dir gesagt 4 minus das war alles so was das
kann nicht sein dann haben sie es besser als wir
alle ja hast du schon echt Unfälle und ich hatte
eine zwei bekommen voll ungerecht ich habe gar
keine zwei verdient um ehrlich zu sein deswegen
[Musik] aus und dann kommt der Lemon Curd
rein und damit eingeräumt und gebacken
ja gar nichts mehr zu tun
aber ja aber Roll cool oder
ja ich mich auch gleich auf dem Tisch gebrochen
danke durchgeben
so das ist nämlich das wunderbare hier an
der Matte und zwar habe ich hier was haben
wir denn hier 28 mal 38 28 x 38 cm habe
ich das jetzt hier ausgerollt auf 3 mm
dicke jetzt kommt Lemon Curd oben drauf und
dann wird das Ganze eingerollt so das Lemon
gehört dass ich jetzt hier benutze das ist
selbst gekauft ist und ich selbstgemachtes
aber ich habe auch ein Rezept auf meinem
Kanal das mache ich mal ganz gerne wenn
ich ganz viel Eigelb übrig habe dann könnt ihr
daraus wunderbar Lemon Karte zubereiten aber
wie gesagt das hier ist jetzt einfach ein
fertiges gekauft ist und das gebe ich jetzt
einfach auf den Teig streicht das schön glatt
und dann wird das einmal aufgeräumt [Musik] so
[Musik] einmal den Geruchstest machen das
riecht richtig lecker und das ganze lasse
ich jetzt noch mal 15 Minuten gehen
man sieht eigentlich schon dass der
Teig extrem fluffig ist aber ich mag es noch
einen Tacken fluffiger wenn ihr die Zeit habt
lass es jetzt noch mal 15 Minuten gehen wenn
jetzt Zeitdruck hat könnt ihr das eigentlich
auch sofort in den Ofen geben wichtig ist
dass der Ofen vorgeheizt ist auf 180 Grad
Ober- und Unterhitze und dann brauchen die Lemon
curd-rolls so ca 25 Minuten und on top mache ich
heute noch ein cream cheese Frosting und das
bereiten wir in der Zwischenzeit zu [Musik]
so für das Zitronencreme cheese Frosting
brauchen wir Doppelrahmfrischkäse Puderzucker
Lemon Curd und Vanilleextrakt das sind
diese vier Zutaten die ihr benötigt und
ich finde Vanille und Zitrone matcht immer
sehr sehr gut daher verzichte ich in dem
Fall auch nicht aufs Vanilleextrakt und das
ganze dann einfach nur ganz kurz verrühren
und anschließend im Anschluss einfach
auf die Lemon curdwords geben [Musik]
[Musik]
so nach dem Backen habe ich ja dann nur noch
das cream cheese Frosting oben drüber gegeben
ja genau
weitergeben da links ich schwarz oder rosa ich
würde auch gerne rosa nehmen bitte schön danke
das muss man mit der Hand essen da
hat keine Gabel was verloren einfach
abrupfen und essen das sieht lecker aus [Applaus]
das ist ein Lemon cream eigentlich
das schmeckt heftig wenn man denkt bei warmen
Temperaturen ist man nicht so der Hefeteig Fan das
ist ein totales sommerrezept finde ich das geht
das ganze Jahr über aber es ist total erfrischend
ne total Zitrone richtig zitronisch und fluffig
also gar nicht kompakt oder so und das ging ja
auch echt also es ging auch wirklich schnell das
wird kein Rezept wo Ewigkeiten braucht lecker
[Musik]
richtig lecker Leute macht es unbedingt nach
eines meiner Top favorite zitronenrezepte
die Hände wäscht man sich nicht nacheinander
also was wünschen wir viel Spaß beim Nachbacken
also ich wünsche mir dass ihr eure Männer oder
eure Freunde oder Mütter oder sonst irgendwas
glücklich macht damit oder schmeckt echt lecker
und sagen bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]